let me ask you what you think your uh
the biggest domestic priority is for you
right now
uh well ultimately let me and i'll tell
you it was happening we created the
greatest economy in the history of our
country
and the other side you know that's not
true it is totally true
virtually every number was the best we
had the best economy ever
and what was happening is things were
coming together i asked you what's the
priority i mean those are all the good
things priority now
is to get back to normal get back to
where we were
to have the economy rage and be great
with
jobs and everybody be happy and that's
where we're going and that's where we're
heading and who
is our biggest foreign adversary
i would say china they're an adversary
they're a competitor they're a foe in
many ways but they're
an adversary i think what happened was
disgraceful
should never have happened should they
should never have allowed
this plague to get out of china and go
throughout the world
188 countries should never have happened
the president ended up cutting that
interview